[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit heinz
wolf uns marietta slomka guten abend die
unbeugsamen heißt ein dokumentarfilm in
dem auf teils sehr unterhaltsame aber
auch erschreckende weise erzählt wird
wie es deutschen politikerinnen ergangen
ist in der bundesdeutschen politik vor
allem zu bonner zeiten einer der für
diesen film interviewten frauen die
inzwischen 77-jährige ursula männle von
der csu sagt darin es braucht halt alles
seine zeit weil es ein kampf um macht
ist und natürlich haben männer dabei
etwas zu verlieren wir müssen deutlich
machen dass ist besser ist wenn frauen
und männer gemeinsam etwas tun
den frauen in der spd scheint dass
gerade gelungen zu sein nicht der mann
der ist so gerne wollte sondern eine
frau soll neue bundestagspräsidentin
werden bärbel bas ist damit erst die
dritte in diesem habt annemarie renger
von der spd war
1972 die erste
bundestagspräsidentin nach ihr hat es
bisher nur noch eine weitere gegeben
1988 wurde rita süßmuth von der cdu in
das amt gewählt und wer die neue ist
berichtet lasdin st
viele bilder von ihr sind dem archiv
nicht zu finden bärbel bas machte
politik bislang aus der zweiten reihe
des bundestags jetzt aber winkt eins der
wichtigsten ämter dass dieses land zu
vergeben hat das mit dem vorschlag
bärbel bas eine sozialdemokraten mit
einer großen biografie eine gute wahl
nicht nur für die spd fraktion sondern
für den bundestag und als zweites
höchste staatsamt in diesem land auch
für die bundesrepublik deutschland ist
viermal holte die frau die hier
fotografiert ein direktmandat als
parlamentarische geschäftsführerin und
stellvertretende fraktionsvorsitzende
lernte sie die regeln des parlaments
kennen in ihrer partei und fraktion ist
sie eher links verortet den agenda
reformen jedenfalls stand sie anders als
der genosse neben ihr kritisch gegenüber
wenn man vorher schon den weg der reform
mitgegangen ist unter schröder ist man
da schon recht
schmerzlich produkt eigentlich wollte
fraktionschef mütze nicht den kosten das
aber hätte bedeutet dass alle wichtigen
staatsämtern
bundespräsident bundeskanzler und eben
auch der bundestagspräsident in
männerhand wären das dürfe bei einer
partei die mit dem parits versprechen
wahlkampf gemacht hat nicht sein am ende
obsiegte der innerparteiliche druck wir
haben ein weibliches gesicht einer
kompetenten frauen gut vernetzten frau
auf dem stuhl der bundestagspräsidentin
platziert es werden keine
nachrichtensendungen gebracht werden
ohne dass deutlich wird in der mitte der
politik in deutschland sitzt eine frau
die erwartungen sind hoch vielleicht
auch weil die bislang zwei einzigen
frauen an der spitze annemarie renger
und rita süssmuth charismatiker rinnen
ihrer zeit waren lob kommt heute
ausgerechnet von dem künftigen
koalitionspartner der für sich selber
quoten strikt ablehnt das
vorschlagsrecht liegt bei der
sozialdemokratischen bundestagsfraktion
als der größte dieses hauses spd hat
sich entschieden für die kollegin bars
die wir kennen und als persönlichkeit
auch schätzen 16 jahre lang lag der
posten bei der union auch norbert
lammert und wolfgang schäuble haben ihre
spuren hinterlassen
phantomschmerzen löst das aber offenbar
nicht aus jede amtsinhaberin und jeder
amtsinhaber bringt natürlich die eigene
persönlichkeit den eigenen
erfahrungshorizont mit ein und da finde
ich es auch ein gebot der fairness dass
man jedem die chance gibt seine eigenen
fußspuren zu hinterlassen noch wird
geschraubt im bundestag nächste woche
ist konstituierende sitzung wenn bärbel
bas gewählt wird steht nach fast einem
vierteljahrhundert wieder eine frau an
der spitze des parlaments
in berlin bei der diskussion darüber ob
mann oder frau da wurde ja auch auf
schloss bellevue geschaut ist das thema
damit jetzt durch also zumindest für den
moment ja denn mit der heutigen
entscheidung
ist ja wenigstens mal eines von fünf
spitzenämtern mit einer frau besetzen
das nimmt erst einmal den druck von
frank walter steinmeier der ja schon im
frühjahr bekundet hat dass er gerne für
eine zweite amtszeit antreten würde und
dabei auch von spd und fdp unterstützt
worden ist die spd hat heute mit dieser
entscheidung zumindest haarscharf den
eindruck vermieden dass sie zwar im
wahlkampf die gleichstellung auf ihre
fahnen geschrieben hat dann aber bei der
ersten gelegenheit wo es um wirklich
hohe staatsämter geht die sache schon
wieder über bord geworfen hat das wird
noch nicht ganz ausgeschlossen ist dass
das amt des bundespräsidenten noch
einmal in die debatte gerät das haben
wir heute aber auch gehört in eine
äußerung von rolf mützenich der schon
sagte es sollte jetzt bitte nicht mehr
weiter politisch über dieses amt
debattiert werden das zeigt das war doch
noch eine befürchtung da ist dass es
noch mal kommen könnte mit blick auf das
paritätisch hat die spd mit dieser
entscheidung jetzt auch den grünen etwas
wind aus den segeln genommen denn die
hatten ja auch durchaus gerne eine ihrer
frauen in einem sehr hohen amt gesehen
ja diesen ehrgeiz werden sie vermutlich
auch nicht gänzlich aufgeben man wird
sehen wie weit der dann reicht es geht
ja jetzt im ab morgen in die
koalitionsverhandlungen
da wird auch in den nächsten wochen
ernsthaft um posten gerungen werden
müssen und da ist auch noch olaf scholz
der schon weit vor dem wahlkampf
versprochen hatte dass er sein kabinett
wenn der kanzler werden sollte
mindestens zur hälfte mit frauen
besetzen möchte und er hat auch schon
klar gemacht dass fdp und grüne da ihren
beitrag zu leisten müssen also das thema
frauen in spitzenpositionen
das wird uns in den nächsten wochen auf
jeden fall wieder ereilen dankeschön
stunde lang nach berlin es gab heute
noch eine personalie die schlagzeilen
macht und auch bei den
koalitionsverhandlungen noch eine rolle
spielen könnte denn damit ist plötzlich
ein weiterer interessanter posten neu zu
besetzen
bundesbank präsident jens weidmann tritt
zurück aus persönlichen gründen wie er
sagt ob es wirklich nur persönliche
gründe sind darüber wird spekuliert
zweit mann gilt als schärfster kritiker
der aktuellen geldpolitik der
europäischen zentralbank
peter wagner und markus wolsiffer
berichten
es scheint ein anderes zeitalter und ist
doch nur zehn jahre her die jugendliche
bundespräsident christian wulff
überreicht dem jugendlichen neuen
bundesbank präsidenten jens weidmann die
ernennungsurkunde als nachfolger von
axel weber wie weit man seinen kindern
erklärt was seine arbeit ist das klang
seiner zeit im zdf interview so kann das
relativ einfach erklären dass ich dafür
sorge trage dazu dass das geld was ihr
im portemonnaie haben auch morgen noch
so viel wert ist wie heute
dafür hat die bundesbank unter jens
weidmann stets gekämpft gegen immer
größere widerstände im rat der
europäischen zentralbank
so kann man jens weidmanns heutigen
abschiedsbrief an sein team verstehen
eine stabilitätsorientierte geldpolitik
wird dauerhaft nur möglich sein wenn der
ordnungsrahmen der währungsunion die
einheit von handeln und haften sichert
die geldpolitik ihr enges mandat achtet
und nicht ins schlepptau der
fiskalpolitik oder der finanzmärkte
gerät weidmann hoch angesehen in der
deutschen öffentlichkeit war mehr und
mehr isoliert im ezb rat seine mahnungen
vor den inflationsgefahren der
ausufernden anleihekäufe fanden kaum
gehör der ezb rat wird ja dominiert von
den vertretern der hoch verschuldeten
länder die für eine lockere geldpolitik
sind und ich erwarte nach dem rücktritt
von herrn weidmann mehr denn je dass die
ezb auch nach einem ende des pep
anleihekaufprogramms weiter im großen
stil staatsanleihen kaufen wird
ezb-präsident in lagarde beschreibt weit
man heute als einen loyalen persönlichen
freund jens hat eine klare haltung zur
geldpolitik doch ich war stets
beeindruckt von seinem willen im ezb rat
nach gemeinsamkeiten zu suchen
weidmann hat seinen rückzug weit vor der
wahl entschieden heißt es aus seinem
umfeld jetzt hätte also jede mögliche
koalition getroffen in das
personaltableau der ampel koalitionäre
kommt dadurch zusätzlicher zündstoff
noch-finanzminister scholz würdigte
seine verdienste
grünen-chef habig sieht die chance für
eine modernisierung der bundesbank und
die fdp warnt vor inflation
die deutsche bundesbank muss weiter an
welchen einer stabilitätsorientierten
geldpolitik in europa bleiben wir sehen
inzwischen
inflationsrisiken in europa die ezb ist
zur eigenen macht am main geworden daran
wird auch der oder die künftige
bundesbank präsidenten kaum etwas ändern
können
das war nur noch ein bisschen vertiefen
valerie haller wie wird der rücktritt in
der frankfurter finanzwelt gesehen war
dabei weit man auch frust im spiel oder
wird das gleich überinterpretiert er
selbst hat er ja nur persönliche gründe
angegeben aber man wagt sich vermutlich
nicht zu weit aus dem fenster wenn man
sagt dass weidmann zuletzt ziemlich
allein auf weiter flur war mit seiner
haltung zur europäischen geldpolitik er
stand dafür ein dass die notenbanken
unabhängig von den begehrlichkeiten der
politik und der finanzmärkte bleiben
sollten die anleihekäufe die
unterstützte er aber eben auch nur
solange sie ausschließlich in notzeiten
zum einsatz kamen hilfe per notenpresse
sei sagte er wie eine droge durchsetzen
konnte er sich mit seiner haltung
allerdings oft nicht
und mit der niedrigzinspolitik der ezb
ezb dürfte das ja jetzt auch dessen
ungeachtet weiter gehen oder ja davon
kann man ausgehen zumal sich die ezb ja
vor kurzem erst mehr flexibilität
genehmigt hat dass das inflationsziel
angeht also künftig darf es ruhig eine
zeit lang auch ein bisschen mehr in
nation sein ohne dass die zentralbank
eingreifen muss ja die befürworter der
lockeren geldpolitik sind im ezb rat
also diesem
entscheidungsgremium in der mehrzahl und
mit weit man geht ein einflussreicher
nein sage in einer zeit steigender
inflation der nein sagen vermutlich
wichtiger ist denn je zu seinem abschied
jedenfalls weit man kann es nicht lassen
warnte er noch mal vor
inflationsgefahren die solle die ezb
nicht aus dem blick verlieren schon
bezeichnet diese aussage kurz vor dem
rückzug dankeschön nach frankfurt
wählerin und
jetzt den nachrichten von heinz wolf die
bundesanwaltschaft hat zwei frühere
bundeswehr soldaten festnehmen lassen
sie sollen am aufbau einer mehr als 100
mann starken söldnertruppe gearbeitet
haben laut bundesanwaltschaft wollten
sie mit einer einheit in den bürgerkrieg
im jemen eingreifen motiv geld die
beiden sind jetzt in untersuchungshaft
ermittelt wird nun wegen der versuchten
gründung einer terroristischen
vereinigung
der russische kremlkritiker alexej
nawalny wird vom europäischen parlament
mit dem sacharow preis für
menschenrechte ausgezeichnet
er habe unermüdlich für grundlegende
freiheiten in seinem land gekämpft so
die begründung dies habe ihn seine
eigene freiheit und fast sein leben
gekostet nach einem giftanschlag
vergangenes jahr kehrte navalny im
januar 2021 nach russland zurück seitdem
sitzt der 45-jährige dort in haft
in moskau kamen bei einer von russland
organisierten afghanistan-konferenz
hochrangige vertreter der taliban und
diplomaten aus zehn ländern zusammen
unter ihnen china pakistan und iran
es riefen die militant islamistischen
taliban zur gewährleistung eines
dauerhaften friedens und zur achtung der
menschenrechte in dem land am hindukusch
auf die taliban appellierten an die
internationale gemeinschaft gelder für
den wiederaufbau afghanistans
bereitzustellen
österreich führt die 3g regel am
arbeitsplatz ein ab 1 november demnach
müssen beschäftigte die am arbeitsort
mit anderen in kontakt kommen nachweisen
dass sie entweder geimpft genesen oder
getestet sind fehlt der nachweis drohen
arbeitgebern und arbeitnehmern
geldstrafen in österreich haben knapp 62
prozent der gesamtbevölkerung einen
vollen impfschutz gegen coop 19 die
sieben tage incidents lag zuletzt bei 1
ein untersuchungsausschuss in brasilien
wirft präsident alvaro
politisches fehlverhalten und
scharlatanerie im umgang mit der korona
pandemie vor von verbrechen gegen die
menschlichkeit wird in dem über 1000
seiten langen bericht gesprochen
personal habe gegen alle ratschläge
gehandelt keine schutzmaßnahmen
ergriffen und das virus verharmlost
brasilien verzeichnet mehr als 21
millionen corona infektionen und über
600.000 todesfälle tausende tote so der
bericht seien vermeidbar gewesen
und wie geht es bei uns mit corona
weiter noch gesundheitsminister sparen
drängt ja darauf ende november die
epidemische notlage zu beenden bzw nicht
mehr zu verlängern das hat zunächst aber
nur juristische folgen damit gäbe es
dann keine bundeseinheitliche
rechtsgrundlage mehr für corona
maßnahmen die bundesländer müssten
jeweils selbst in ihren parlamenten
beschließen dass weiterhin bestimmte
maßnahmen notwendig sind was sie wohl
auch tun würden insofern wäre das
förmliche ende der bundesgesetzlich
erklärten notlage keineswegs einen
freedom day wie in großbritannien wo ja
im juli mit einem schlag gerona für
beendet erklärt wurde was auch in
großbritannien viele inzwischen für
einen schweren fehler halten kein
anderes westeuropäisches land hat so
hohe infektionszahlen aktuell 50.000
neue am tag und jetzt wird auch noch
eine neue mutter beobachtet andreas
stamm berichtet
so sollte das land gut über den winter
kommen mit der dritten corona impfung
für 30 millionen ältere und meist
gefährdete doch viele große impfzentren
abgebaut das impfprogramm läuft nur noch
schleppend und das habe erklärt david
garfinkel zum tod seines vaters geführt
der 76 jährige wartete auf den dritten
impftermin
hat untersuchungstermine im krankenhaus
wahrgenommen dann bekam er corona
elf tage später ist er gestorben die
auffrischung hätte sein leben gerettet
rohr incident aber durch hohe impfquoten
moderate zahlen bei schweren verläufen
und todesfällen seitdem in england alle
beschränkungen aufgehoben wurden schien
die regierungsstrategie aufzugehen doch
das blatt wendet sich 223 gemeldete tote
gestern fast 1000 menschen mussten ins
krankenhaus und unter den steigenden
fallzahlen sind wieder viele über 80 ein
alarmzeichen
wir haben erstens kaum mehr
abstandsregeln und ähnliches im
vergleich zum rest europas und zweitens
noch wichtiger schwächt sich der
immunschutz durch impfung oder durch
eine natürliche infektion definitiv ab
vor allem die schutzwirkung des in
großbritannien meistgenutzten impfstoffs
von astrazeneca lasse mit der zeit wohl
deutlicher nach ergänzt hunter aber der
fall israel habe gezeigt auch bei
anderen impfstoffen brauche es die
auffrischung dringend zeit zu handeln
erklären nun die spitzen des staatlichen
gesundheitsdienstes nhs masken pflicht
in teilen wieder einführen einlass bei
massenveranstaltungen nur für geimpfte
zurück ins home office wo es möglich ist
die wahl ist doch einfach akzeptieren
wir die überwältigenden beweise aus
allen teilen des gesundheitssystems und
tun was wir können ohne uns wirklich
stark einschränken zu müssen oder
drücken wir die daumen hoffen auf ein
wunder und stolpern dann wieder wie
schon so oft in die nächste krise
zeit für plan b so die frage an den
premier doch die regierung will von
beschränkungen noch nichts wissen man
erwarte in den kommenden wochen bis zu
100.000 fälle am tag so der
gesundheitsminister bei einer sonder
pressekonferenz mehr schwere verläufe
mehr tote wohl unvermeidlich trotzdem
keine verbote dafür ein appell an die
vernunft mit drohendem unterton
wenn wir all die gewährten freiheiten
behalten wollen dann ist es das beste
wenn jeder sich impfen lässt wenn er
wieder dran ist aber es gibt auch viele
weitere maßnahmen um die ausbreitung des
virus einzudämmen
im freien treffen wenn möglich wenn es
drinnen sein muss gut lüften und wenn es
irgendwo sehr voll ist masken tragen
gefragt warum seine eigene fraktion im
parlament weiter dicht gepackt masken
los auftritt spätestens saerbeck der
minister rat und hilflos währenddessen
beobachten britische forscher eine delta
mutation die noch ansteckender sein soll
und schon verantwortlich für zehn
prozent aller fälle krone steht vor
einem comeback in britannien und
vorsicht oder nachsicht das ist nun
wieder die frage
man konnte horst seehofer heute die wut
anmerken er hat auf den belarussischen
diktator lukaschenko und auf wladimir
putin ohne dessen zustimmung der wähler
russe sein schmutziges geschäft mit
flüchtlingen nicht betreiben würde das
kam mir gestern auch in europa parlament
schon zur sprache beim appell an polen
dem kreml nicht in die hände zu spielen
der vor allem eines will europa die
stabilisieren der streit in der eben
desto besser und kein thema eignet sich
dafür so gut wie flüchtlinge die
auswirkungen der lukaschenko schlepperei
sind inzwischen auch im deutsch
polnischen grenzgebiet zu spüren mal zum
vergleich bis ende juli kamen nur 26
menschen über belarus und polen nach
deutschland
jetzt im oktober sind es schon über
3.000 klaus brodbeck berichtet solche
situationen häufen sich der osten
brandenburgs deutsch-polnisches
grenzgebiet und eine gruppe flüchtende
aufgegriffen von der polizei 100 200
ankommende pro tag waren es hier lange
seit zwei tagen aber gegen die zahl
sprunghaft nach oben allen gemeinsam
bewegt nach westeuropa führt über die
nahrung in
belarus und durch belarus findet eine
staatlich organisierte
zumindest unterstützte schleuser
tätigkeit stadt
und das ist eine form der hybriden
bedrohung in dem man migranten als
politische waffe einsetzt die jetzt nach
deutschland geschafft haben berichten
über strapazen ihrer flucht trinken aus
pfützen aus angst zu verdursten am
morgen hatte der innenminister im
kabinett berichtet beraten wurde hier
auch über gegenmaßnahmen grenzschließung
oft laut und gerne gefordert gehören
nicht dazu
in die schließung der grenze
haben wir heute kurz angesprochen ist
von niemandem beabsichtigt wäre auch
rechtlich
mal vom politischen abgesehen im moment
sehr sehr fragwürdig stattdessen soll
die zusammenarbeit zwischen polnischen
und deutschen behörden noch intensiver
werden bis hin zu gemeinsamen
patrouillen auf polnischer seite
800 schafften hat die bundespolizei
bereits an die grenze verlegt
wenn es dem belarussischen diktator
lukaschenko gelingen würde die polnische
seite und die deutsche seite
gegeneinander auszuspielen wenn es ein
gegeneinander ab dieser beiden
mitgliedstaaten der europäischen union
in der migrationspolitik in dieser frage
gebe dann hätte ja die belarussische
regierung genau das erreicht was sie
will nämlich eine weitere spaltung der
europäischen union kommt flüge nach
minsk aus ländern außerhalb der
europäischen union da müssen wir
ansetzen wir müssen gucken dass diese
flüge unterbunden werden und dass dieser
staatlich organisierter menschenhandel
gestoppt wird noch richten sich
sanktionen und forderungen danach nur
gegen geschenke und dessen regime dabei
werden die strippen in moskau gezogen
ich kann mir nicht vorstellen und da
hatten wir heute auch niemand
widersprochen im kabinett dass das
regime in balance dies alles machen kann
ohne
zumindestens
inkaufnahme oder billigung aus moskau
solche situationen
[Musik]
werden noch häufiger noch sucht europa
nach einem weg gemeinsam auch gegen
putin
und jetzt nochmal heinz mit anderen
meldungen in japan ist einer der
aktivsten vulkane des landes
ausgebrochen über dem im südwesten
japans gelingen vulkanasche keine
tausende meter hohe aschewolke auf
gesteinsbrocken wurden durch die luft
geschleudert
bergsteiger an dem als touristenmagnet
bekannten vulkan wurden in sicherheit
gebracht einsatzkräfte sucht nach
möglicherweise festsitzenden wanderern
verletzte wurden zunächst nicht gemeldet
bevor es gleich in ein paar minuten den
ausführlichen wetterbericht gibt hier
schon mal kurz ein blick auf den wechsel
heute von teils noch schön im oktober
wetter bei dem man wie hier am tegernsee
noch einmal sonne tanken konnte hinzu
windigem herbstwetter wie auf dem
brocken und der zu dem sturmtief das
jetzt über deutschland hinweg zieht der
deutsche wetterdienst warnt ab der nacht
für weite teile deutschlands vor
schweren sturmböen und für einige
regionen hat er sogar bereits
unwetterwarnungen herausgegeben vor
orkanartigen böen in teilen von
nordrhein-westfalen hessen bayern
sachsen und thüringen vor kahn böen in
teilen von baden württemberg und vor
extremen orkanböen in teilen von sachsen
anhalt
ergebnis aus der
fußball-champions-league der vfl
wolfsburg hat bei rb salzburg am abend 1
zu 3 verloren die deutschen bahnrad team
sprinterinnen haben bei der wm in dubai
gold gewonnen die titelverteidigerinnen
am 1 pauline grabosch und lea soviel
friedrich gewannen im finale gegen
russland in weltrekordzeit bronze
sicherte sich das trio aus
großbritannien und jetzt die zahlen vom
lotto am mittwoch sie lauten wie immer
ohne gewähr 7 15 16 24 37 43 superzahl 5
und weitere gewinnzahlen finden sie auf
lotto punkt zdf de und im zdf text auf
seite 55 7
die buchmesse in frankfurt ist natürlich
ein fest für bücher menschen und davon
gibt es glücklicherweise ja sehr viele
es wird viel gelesen viel geschrieben
und viel verlegt das problem ist nur die
verlage haben mittlerweile angst ob sie
den vorbestellungen der buchhändler
überhaupt noch gerecht werden können
denn es fehlt ein entscheidender
rohstoff papier
digitalisierung kenne daher bücher
werden nach wie vor massenhaft auch auf
papier gedruckt das publikum mag papier
zum lesen zum verschenken zum ins regal
stellen doch papier ist mangelware
geworden ich konnte es dazu kommen dara
hassanzadeh mit den hintergründen
selten hat ein museumsbesuch so einen
aktuellen bezug kam war gutenbergs
druckmaschine in betrieb entstand ein
engpass in mainz fehlte es an
hochwertigem papier guttenberg ließ
edles druck papier aus italien kommen
ein paar jahrhunderte später herrscht
wieder papier mangel selbst die großen
in der branche wie der hamburger
rowohlt-verlag sprechen von einer papier
krise es ist nicht mehr die frage
wann und auf welchem papier wir unsere
bücher produzieren sondern die frage ist
vielmehr ob wir unsere bücher überhaupt
bekommen und wie viele wir bekommen
drucken lässt rowohlt auch im
nordfriesischen lag
bis zu 300.000 bücher verlassen die cpi
druckerei pro tag
eine papierrolle 720 kilogramm schwer
wird in 25 minuten zu büchern
verarbeitet hier herrscht täglicher
beschaffungs druck
das tatsächlich so dass die
papierfabriken auch sehr beschränkt sind
gerade in ihren kapazitäten und wir
bekommen sie einfach nicht ran die
materialien und wir sind ganz europa
sucht einig und es ist sehr schwierig zu
tage der papiermarkt ist unter druck die
hersteller setzen auf verpackungspapier
für den online-handel ganze
papierfabriken wurden umgewandelt
transportkosten sind gestiegen dazu
kommen personal und lkw mangel die
verlage verkaufen jetzt mehr bücher weil
sie während der korona locker uns
neuerscheinungen verschoben haben die
holz mangel treibt die preise für
frischen zellstoff in die höhe
besonders schwierig ist der druck
ausgefallener editionen in der digitalen
welt ist gerade das haptische eines
buches auch sein wettbewerbsvorteil und
genau das schätzen die leser sie sind
dem buch auch in der korona zeit treu
geblieben was vor einem jahr klopapier
war ist heute das buch papier es ist vor
kurzem eine schwedische firma
papierfabrik hat sozusagen eine große
kapazität vom markt genommen eine mega
tonne holz freies gestrichenes papier
ist einfach per du und es jetzt
verpackungskarton geworden
und dann wundert man sich und dieses
bild ist natürlich irre wir haben die
inhalte und die welt welt die verpackung
man müsste eigentlich eine kultur
kritisches buch darüber schreiben aber
man hat ja kein papier die papiere krise
kommt zur unzeit die frankfurter
buchmesse öffnet ihre pforten und das
weihnachtsgeschäft steht vor der tür es
ist die zeit die über wohl und wehe
einer ganzen branche entscheidet aber
das buch hat bisher noch jede krise
gemeistert
das war es von uns und passend zu
unseren anfangs thema frauen in der
politik geht es jetzt weiter mit frauen
im fußball während das ja
selbstverständlich ist dass spielerinnen
von männern trainiert werden gibt es das
umgekehrt fast gar nicht ein thema für
zdf so und um 0.45 meldet sich dann da
sagte mir mit unserem heutigen update
wiedersehen wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten abend über dem atlantik hat sich
ein sturmtief entwickelt das ist jetzt
heute über tag schon weitergezogen und
liegt jetzt direkt vor dem ärmelkanal es
wird innerhalb der nächsten 24 stunden
entlang des ärmelkanals und über
deutschland hinweg weiter in richtung
baltikum ziehen und die kräftigsten
windböen die gibt's immer südwestlich
des tiefdruck zentrums dass mit diesen
sturmböen von 75 kilometer pro stunde
und mehr geht schon heute nacht los
zuerst im südwesten in der zweiten
nachthälfte bis zum frühen morgen dann
aber zum beispiel auch in sachsen in
brandenburg und in thüringen auch morgen
über tag pfeift es ordentlich weiter im
westen sind dann schwere sturmböen
möglich und im osten sogar orkanartige
sturmböen orkanböen mit mehr als 117
kilometer pro stunde beschränken sich
aber wohl auf die gipfellagen der
mittelgebirge
morgen abend ist es mit dem stoff schon
im wesentlichen vorbei dann pfeift es
noch hier über der ostsee und über der
nordsee das sturmtief bringt auch viel
regnet im schwarzwald können bis zu 30
liter regen pro quadratmeter fallen
sonst sind kräftige schauer und gewitter
unterwegs heute nacht bei temperaturen
zwischen 16 und 7 grad morgen werden es
dann so 10 bis 18 grad das wird ein
grässlicher donnerstag halten sie sich
von bäumen fern die werden zum teil
umkippen oder erste abreißt auch der
verkehr kann durchaus eingeschränkt
werden am freitag ist es mit dem
kräftigen sturm vorbei dann pfeift es
nur noch in norddeutschland und das
wochenende wird deutlich ruhiger bei
temperaturen zwischen sieben und 14 grad
guten abend